foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I thought you were dead tired I know
from slam of these fat stacks of
Flapjacks whoa what the hell is going on
Flapjack Friday you goofball you know
every Friday we sneak down to the poop
dungeon with a heaping pile of Pancakes
slather that good Razz all over the
floor and just go to Chow Town dog
because raspberry jams are jammed there
he is welcome back bud now are you gonna
sit over there mopen are you gonna come
over here and help me go to pound town
on these bad boys I want to go to Pound
Town yes I do come on what about this
guy
oh yeah no he's dead
oh yeah okay well it doesn't yeah oh
yeah look at you
saw a horror franchise that is so effed
in the a with horrendous acts of
violence and torture that we can't even
show it as b-roll
Nico
your kids like Halloween right they love
Halloween yeah Milo's three Halloween is
her favorite holiday you want to be a
puppy okay let's be puppy what do
puppies say
cow's not even one yet it will be his
first Halloween this Halloween it's very
important to me that he Treasures the
holiday just as much as my problem is
every good Halloween movie or show is
rated R it's like for adults can you
imagine a world Nico where you could
watch Saw with your entire family you
get the best the best Halloween ever
yeah Matt if you did that for me
I would get you a cool guy award
but here's the thing first their mother
must approve make Ivy okay with showing
Saul to my kids Nico we are setting out
to make the most family-friendly Saw
movie the world has ever seen this is
rough stuff but we gotta make him rated
G in order to do that we need to dissect
the scenes weird choice of words
so in this scene there is a swinging
pendulum of death and it's slowly
lowering down onto his stomach and it's
gonna start cutting him oh God there's
nothing happening yet but it's good the
anticipation better nothing's happening
yet he's so scared though
what is something that would be horrible
if you're strapped down what comes to
mind waxing waxing is good 40 year old
virgin thing that's not bad
but he doesn't have any body hair this
was smooth there's one thing the the
idea of getting tickled in a way that's
like you can't do anything about it you
tickle until they don't want to be
tickled anymore and it gets serious real
quick it's rated G yes but it is still
legitimately tortured how do you feel
about needles they're not bad they're
fine
foreign
[Music]
you have to dig through a whole pit of
used needles to find a key to open up
the door
the thing is you know it's worse than a
giant pile of needles is stepping on one
Lego having done both I would agree with
that and it's very kid-friendly
in this trap they have to donate some of
their blood
oh no why did I look but I oh
it's going between the fingers dude
so what do you what are you guys
thinking for this what's happening
they're putting their hands in the Box
what's in the box what's in the box
cute little kittens they're sacrificing
their hands to these cats that they're
allergic to yeah allergic's good because
they're still torture then
this is a crushing device you just
replace that with the idea of too much
love like giant robotic teddy bears come
in and are just hugging
this one the idea is that there's a key
in acid and she needs to reach in and
get it in order to unlock the vest
that's going to rip her ribs out
our initial concept for this one is
you've got to eat your vegetables before
you can have dessert and so it's a jar
of cookies and she's like trying to
reach into the jar of cookies but
there's like a fork or some sort of like
mechanical arm with a fork and a piece
of broccoli like trying to feed it to
her it's like the Ryan Gosling will need
a cereal thing oh yes
there is a key that jigsaw is put inside
of her attached to a string but also
attached to that string is a hook I hate
it this is like not really that Bloody
but it's just to me it had the most
visceral reaction yeah I just like can
feel it
how do you make this rated G Matt what
if it's like two clowns and you know
that those like handkerchiefs yeah it
just keeps pulling them out of her mouth
don't look at it oh God there's one
thing about these movies that I actually
really respect
um and it's not the storyline uh it's
the Practical effects because it's very
visceral and a lot of the times it feels
real and that's why you have these
emotional responses when you watch these
movies it's a testament to the special
effects team it really is very
impressive oh and I hate watching it
though I hate what you've done we will
offer the most flesh well we were
thinking about doing for this one
replacing the butcher's knife with a
mallet and she's doing like whack-a-mole
with a little saw a guy who's just like
popping in and that's pretty good he's
literally just trying to hit it she's
just whack them all trying to whack them
all and it's hard for her
and that's torture
this is a classic saw trap where there's
a metal piece inside of her mouth and
the bear trap just kind of Springs open
and then oh he rips her face open the
whole face is gone I legitimately don't
want to do this video I have one
question for you boys
do you want to play a game
I'm in yeah plate photography to stay
true to the saw ethos which is to do as
much practical as possible quack
those moles a little more a little more
there you go
go
like that easy right we are essentially
looking at the lighting we're looking at
the framing and we are getting our
assets to match those things as close as
possible as we can to make the
compositing even easier and three two
one action
okay completely unnecessary but uh thank
you we've got a series of plates for all
the shots that we need and again you
can't beat the detail of real life
okay it's already G we got a lot of
great ideas a lot of scenes that we're
gonna remix and make funny but we can't
just have a collection of VFX Clips here
we need a story we need a framing device
uh some kind of world that these clips
exist in I'm thinking we create a
streaming service kidney plus you get it
you'll get it get it because kids get it
and organs in a non-legally threatening
way get it kidney plus is geared towards
children they've decided to remaster all
of the Saw movies uh to be fun for the
whole family I went back and forth on if
we're gonna have a little kidney mascot
but he's just so stupid I gotta put him
in man he's dangling on the plus sign I
don't give a [ __ ] but anyway this whole
trailer is also driven by a narration so
we typed Disney voice into fiverr.com
and we found this guy get a dozen gooey
minis for your little monster maybe I
can do your gooey Minis
that he's recording that right now and I
think we have to record some of own
voiceover as well
alright so this is the Oink Oink Pig guy
weird job broccoli no
broccoli
moles what the balls
there's feathers tickling him I think
the only way we can do that
is tickling me practical effects
foreign
[Laughter]
this is why I can't get pedicures
straight up that's it folks we're done
with everything we don't we just need to
show the video nothing else needs to be
done just the visual effects aside from
all of the visual things
Rock Paper Scissors Shoot
it looks like I'm gonna be the one
that's forced to do this horrible face
ripping apart shot but you know what I'm
a big boy I think I'll be fine I'm gonna
check out the plate now and see what I
have to do on this shot
foreign
I can't do it
I think I can yeah yeah I'll do the shot
I'm gonna make this so clean that you
can watch it without worry oh thank you
man turns out saw rated G was for me
the point of this shot was to take this
super gruesome bear trap and make it not
gory so instead of ripping a head apart
it's just brushing teeth the easiest way
to do that is just simply just replace
the actress with someone who's not
covered in blood if we look at the
original footage here this actress and
my wife look very similar I used to be
the actor in all of Run's old old old
videos on his regulator Channel and I'm
here for it yeah this is the eyeliner
the contraption opens to reveal a couple
like a little electric toothbrushes
going and you're like that was good
thank you for coming in thanks for
buying me coffee do you know how to get
me please
now that I have the plates that's where
the fun stuff Begins the problem solving
all right he's gone we have the whole
head piece in the background that all
should stay so Roto out the headpiece
and the jacket and put her underneath
all of that so once the thing opens up
chop that frame and turn the rest of it
into just a still frame so technically
the rest of this shot here is completely
still I used mocha Pro's mesh tracking
features for this and mesh tracked Jenna
and applied that mesh track to the still
frame Roto so even though the whole shot
is a freeze frame all of the pieces of
the original image actually move the
same way Jenna does I feel like that was
the key ingredient to make this shot
work I'm not even going to talk about
the little rendered toothbrushes that
was just a fun little addition once I
add the Grain and the slow zoom and the
little glint I think are you gonna add a
sound effect for the little glint oh
I think I have now made this shot
palatable for Fenner hey Fenner you want
to see the shot I did this for you oh
thanks man Nico's kids are gonna love it
oh God red
show you the original I saw it
oh do you want to play a game
uh let me tell you something very
special to tell you about quarter
Digital Dot store okay everything in the
store is on sale and there's going to be
deeper and deeper discounts as we get
closer to the holidays it's the gone for
good sale meaning that everything in the
store is on sale and there's no
guarantee that it will ever be offered
again but there's one catch the deeper
the discounts get the lower the stock
gets so here's how this works so
starting on October 31st everything in
the store is going to be 25 off and then
on November 14th everything in the store
is going to be 40 off and then on
November 21st everything in the store is
going to be 50 off and starting on Cyber
Monday everything in the store is going
to be 75 off but that's not all oh
that's that's not all if you're a member
of quarterdigital.com you get an
additional 15 percent off on top of the
discounts that I just mentioned but the
longer you wait the less of a chance
there will be that the thing you want is
in stock and so the choice
is up to you go to Corridor Digital Dot
store now jigsaw
friend has graciously volunteered to
take care of the head exploding shot
because I did not want to do that
instead the most iconic shot in all of
song apparently this guy at the end
spoiler alert that's jigsaw lying in
this Blood this is for the kids we can't
have them lie in there in blood but what
we could make him do is be the ultimate
pie eating champion so we've got these
pies why do we have these pies you ask
why can't we just make cgis of these
pies well the answer is
I don't want to that's not the saw way
the saw way is practical that's what we
do so Fenner came up with a great
solution of hey why don't we print out
our buddy here stick it into the pie and
then scan that pie with our buddy
polycam it's our first real life bull oh
that's really clever yeah I like that we
finished the scan now it's time to wait
nobody touched this pie
my continuity oh it worked
it's like the Trench Run made of pie now
I can do an AR pie oh my God
so we successfully scanned our pie and
now it's in the computer and how did it
turn out you might ask oh he's in the
pie the nice thing about photo scanning
this is we got all of the little
imperfections that you get in an actual
pie it has all the little crumbs that
broke when we pushed our little IRL
Boolean into that you've got the little
specular hits on the raspberry jelly
doesn't just look realistic it looks
delicious oh it's so pretty that's
pretty good you just you're not going to
get a model online like that I'm
basically adding things like our kind of
contact Shadows so that the raspberry
filling on the inside is sort of
shadowing our Dead Guy a little bit so
once we get him in the shot there he's
just sitting in that pie but how do we
know he's the best we have to make him
the pie eating champ 2004 and we're able
to add that onto his T-shirt to really
sell that this is not blood this is not
Gore this is family friendly baked goods
can we eat that pie now raspberry pie
oh yeah it is cherry pie star oh
we couldn't find a Raspberry Pi I'm
sorry yeah we'll just get back to work
I'd rather work than I'd rather work
okay so yeah things get disappointing
real quick over there
what's a rated G version of a pit of
needles it would be like just a bunch of
candy that you can't open right it's
just a bunch of like glasses
oh yeah oh I thought I was alone Orchard
yeah okay yeah it's not that it's Legos
this would really suck so in this pit I
calculated that there should be about
two million Lego and this is based on no
signs at all look I'm not Ren okay so I
just eyeballed it but there's no need to
over exert the system when we're not
actually interacting with the stuff
that's underneath the surface my
Approach was to have two separate layers
of Lego the base level that I don't need
to simulate and then the top active pile
of Lego 50 000 strong that can be
interacted with and splashed up and
simulated and from there I animated a
character digging through the Lego like
she was doing in the actual scene and I
use that as a collider in the simulation
with the active Lego and what you've got
was a real nice realistic match of the
splash that you see with the needles in
your original shot and all of a sudden
when everything is put together with the
motion blurs and all the other final
little compositing tweaks the Legos feel
like they're in there oh that's good I'm
glad you did your research yeah it looks
well we do very important things here in
the corridor and a lot of people
why'd you laughed at that no not at all
I uh
yeah because Sincere we do important
it needs to be done 100 yeah so you're
welcome we're gonna bring the family
together we're gonna bring Nico and his
family together
we finally done it we have all the VFX
in place we have an awesome sound mix
and now we're ready to show the crew how
we made saw G-rated
oh wow everybody's here already that's
crazy it's crazy how that works hey guys
hi Matt oh it's a long journey getting
here wasn't it but uh we have something
for you Nico I'm doubtful but willing to
have my mind changed I have a boy who
isn't even one yet PG is too spicy for
him you need to cut that pee off the G
this needs to be General audiences Nico
I think we kicked that P right out of
that g really yeah yeah yep with this
piece right here this food Cobra on
kidney plus gather all your little
ghouls and goblins for an exclusive
remastering of a beloved Halloween
classic it's song rated G all the goose
you love from the original series now
safe for the whole family
you find yourself here today to make a
choice your bad eating habits have left
you weak and feeble late night snacking
will not nope nope nope Karen see this
is what I'm talking about no cookies
until you finish your vegetables
join us as our friend jigsaw teaches
valuable life lessons to those in need
like the importance of good dental
hygiene cleaning up toys after playtime
loving your neighbor
and much much more
[Music]
today you will put your allergies to the
test
whoa Raspberry Pi save me some song
rated G nice and fairly friendly it's a
family friendly trailer for the masses
Sam what is the face uh what do you what
do you got what do you got for us there
Sam uh do you have to have like a
do you have fun do you have an edgier
cut without any of the visual effects
yeah this is for babies you've made saw
for babies did we maybe even get to
lowercase G status yeah
yes yes we did it
yes
not so fast guys uh-oh what's going on
here not too bad but
it doesn't matter what I think it
doesn't matter it's saying things it
doesn't matter what anyone in here
thinks it really matters
what the mom thinks hello Ivy hello how
are you we're all here I want you to
watch this trailer and I want you to
tell me honestly and authentically
would you be okay showing this to Milo
and Calvin
C Is For Cookie
oh she's oh that's I don't know if
that's well it could be
hmm
that's tough
what about it makes it tough I mean what
I think the clown is too scary oh no
hold on the interest is scary no no oh
no okay can I can I can I speak to this
you know when we were when we were
brainstorming this we still wanted
something that was in the horror genre
for the children so still in the G
category but but we'll still spark a
little bit of fear in the children you
know in a nice way in a in a g way I'm
there would be some extra explanations
mainly because
you're going what are we watching I
think with the right context
as long as you're like it's 10.
I think Milo would be okay watching it
okay that's a yes that's a yes that's a
g rating baby
if a parent has to step in and explain
something that is Parental Guidance now
Parental Guidance also known as
PG
I can't believe we were so close you
guys are so close it was so close
next time we'll just talk to you
directly go to the source all right
thanks Ivy love you bye
the measure here was whether or not we
could watch it as a family PG
technically you can still get by and
watch the family and it sounds like you
guys achieved that and you know for all
the hard work you put in Matt I did
promise you one thing
[Music]
it's rated good so oh that's so cute
thank you thank you buddy thanks I
appreciate it
[Music]
so Sam I heard earlier that you were
asking for the edgy version the R-rated
treatment right we're going back to to
Basics here yeah well if you want to see
all of that Saucy goodness you can head
on over to Corridor digital.com
I hate that so much